jesse the recording company
loves our video you want to see us
perform live yeah it's all set the
producer is coming to the max tomorrow
night to see you guys sing
hey that's great yeah we rehearsed
tonight oh
i can't tonight i have to study
tomorrow's the midterm jesse hey
i'll sit next to you and you can copy
off of me
i may as well take poison now
come on it won't take that long are you
ready for that test jess
okay oh all right rehearse and then i'll
study afterwards all right
hey jesse there's this quiz i have to
take in english you got a pin i could
borrow
yeah there's one in my book bag help
yourself all right
what are these doing here i believe you
were looking for this
jesse those pills are dangerous yeah
well so is geometry
you told me you were gonna stop taking
them i need them to stay
awake and study okay no it's not okay
jesse i'm worried about you give me the
pills mind your business
[Music]
great earrings lisa ask me anything
about geometry i'm ready i'm ready
jesse are you all right great wonderful
terrific check this out
the square of the hypotenuse of a right
triangle is equal to the sums of the
square of the other two sides baby
uh you sure you don't want to check this
over
no mr dewey i aced it i know it i really
studied
get number six right even i couldn't
figure it out
the square root of a b over two thanks
[Music]
jesse
[Applause]
ladies you guys are awesome do that
tonight we're on our way
yeah yeah all right screech
when the producer gets here make sure he
sits right in front of the stage
got it all right lisa you'll bring the
costumes i'll pick you up okay
good good everyone be here by seven
jesse will come together okay
hands in a circle
there we go one two three hot sand day
one will be great we'll be awesome we'll
lock them down right
right yeah
jesse
jesse hey wake up
come on we got to go to max come on
jesse
come on zach what time is it
i had to take my diy test why you
already took the test
i did yeah yeah at 6 30. come on we got
to go
let's go where are we going where are we
going
you're singing tonight singing
yeah tonight can wait what am i gonna
wear
jesse remember lisa's bringing your
costume
right i got to wash my hair no there's
no time no
time there's never any time i don't have
time to study
i'll never get into stanford i'll let
everyone down i'm so confused
jesse hey hey just calm down
it's okay you're right it's okay
everything will be okay
yeah i just need one of these pills
you mean you really are taking drugs i
need them jesse give me those
i have to sing seat you can't sing
tonight
i'm so excited i'm so
excited i'm so
scared jesse just
jesse hey don't be scared
listen we'll get through this
hey come on
remember that time when we when we snuck
out to cet
riding home on our bikes it was so dark
and we were scared come on
you